there is a second huge story from the
leaked audio recording of this dinner
that Donald Trump had with left Parnas
who he claims not to know as well as
igor Fuhrman both rudy guiliani henchmen
who have since been indicted Donald
Trump's comments in the recording
confirm that Donald Trump is scared of
Bernie Sanders now this is very
interesting because a couple of weeks
ago I got a live call during during our
audience call segment from a viewer who
said hey David have you noticed that
Trump doesn't really criticize Bernie
much he goes after Biden he goes after
Warren but he doesn't he went after
Hillary and still goes after Hillary but
he doesn't really go after Bernie
Sanders very much and it's basically
truth from calls him crazy Bernie he's
nicknamed him but he doesn't really go
hard against Bernie and we suspected it
could be that Donald Trump actually is
sort of scared of Bernie he thinks
Bernie could actually do well against
him in the recording Donald Trump
actually admits this in the audio I'm
about to play for you Donald Trump
admits that if Hillary had chosen Bernie
as her running mate in 2016 instead of
milquetoast Tim Kaine that it would have
been tougher for Trump that Bernie as
Trump sees it Bernie is similar on trade
he has a similar message people are
getting screwed on trade that Bernie
would have been a tougher opponent and
this is part of a long recording that
was leaked this part hasn't been getting
as much attention it really should let's
take a listen to it yeah Jane was
but I think our knees you know because
all those people that ended here so much
who voted for me you know I get quite
the center burn a lot of people know a
little stuff because the trick because
he's a big jerk anyways basically and
he's right I'm worse than he is but we
can do something and she picked Bernie
Sanders who would have been tougher the
only one I didn't it's right there we've
suspected this for a long time and there
is Donald from saying it now Trump is
wrong on on facts all the time Trump may
have been scared of Bernie for no reason
like what I mean is just because Trump
believes Bernie would have been the
toughest to run against this VP doesn't
mean Bernie would have been the toughest
to run against this VP maybe he would
maybe he wouldn't that's not actually
what we're debating here but this is
terrific fodder for Bernie Sanders to
now run on and even include in ads Trump
said he's afraid of Bernie Sanders and
case in point as an example of just
because Trump thinks something doesn't
mean it's true
in that audio I played for you Trump
says I got 20% of Bernie voters that's
not true it was half that Trump was off
by by half one out of ten Bernie
supporters ultimately voted for Trump
not two out of ten and that's roughly in
line with the percentage of of other
party switches in the past Hillary
supporters in 2008 that ultimately voted
for John McCain for example instead of
Barack Obama still shocking to me I
don't agree with it and Trump doesn't
even remotely seem like a reasonable
substitute to Bernie unless you're
trying to burn it all down because your
candidate lost but one out of ten Bernie
supporters did ultimately vote for Trump
in 2016 regardless this is a gift if you
are Bernie Sanders this is something
that should be repeated by campaign
surrogates used in campaign ads and made
a huge deal of by Bernie Sanders any
reasonable person would also say well
Trump also seems to be afraid of Biden
he extorted Ukraine to smear Biden and
he didn't do that for other possible
opponents that's certainly true but this
helps Bernie's image
so let's now give it a few days we'll
see if this is used by the Sanders
campaign whether it moves the needle in
any way I actually don't know how many
people are following the entire leaked
audio story there was surprisingly less
coverage of it than I imagined there
would be there was other news over the
weekend including the tragic death of
Kobe Bryant with without passing without
passing any value judgments it took a
lot of media coverage hours and this
leaked audio thing particularly the
Bernie Trump part did not get a lot of
attention but this tape as I said
earlier must be made part of the
impeachment trial evidence it will put
it in front of more people and Bernie
Sanders should also be using this to
bolster his own campaign we'll continue
covering this on Instagram make sure you
were following us on instagram at david
pakman show while you're there follow me
on instagram at David Pakman as well I
know that the David Pakman show audience
is full of curious and creative people
who love learning new things and
bettering themselves and that's why I'm
so excited to tell you about one of our
sponsors Skillshare the vibrant online
learning community that offers thousands
of classes on almost any topic you can
imagine and you'll get full access to
the entire library of classes for two
entire months free when you go to david
pakman.com slash skill all of the
classes are taught by experts in their
fields they've got classes on drawing
painting photography video editing web
design bookkeeping marketing personal
productivity doesn't even scratch the
surface I recently took a class about
photography if anybody follows me on
instagram you know that my photography
skills leave much to be desired and it
was great I got so much out of it and
hopefully you will see the fruits of me
taking that class reflected in my
Instagram pictures sooner than later
they have classes for every skill level
whether you're wanting to get better at
something you already have experience
with you want to learn something totally
new to you you set your own pace classes
are usually less than an hour long
they're divided up into bite-size
segments so you can easily fit them into
your schedule make 2020 a year where you
explore new skills
deep in existing passions get lost in
creativity Skillshare really makes it
easier than ever
Skillshare memberships are less than ten
bucks a month and that gives you access
to the thousands of classes they offer
but everybody in the David Pakman show
audience gets a Skillshare membership
totally free for two whole months just
go to david pakman.com slash skill
that's david pakman.com slash s ki ll